well this is the penultimate class so
we're almost done the whole course began
in the fall of last year starting with
more or less than Neolithic Revolution
which is universally accepted as sort of
a major change point in in human
experience I've become increasingly
skeptical of its utility as a starting
point because it seems to me that by the
way the Neolithic Revolution is defined
focusing primarily on grain growing and
the Egypt and Mesopotamia and other old
world places that if it fails to look at
many of the interesting phenomena that
are happening at the same time or
roughly the same time in other areas and
therefore from the very outset when you
take that as the beginning of your
narrative you're preparing the way for a
history that gives special legitimacy to
the ancient Near East and to those
things that are now looked upon as being
the successors the ancient Near East
let's say ancient Greece ancient Rome
and medieval Europe and modern Europe
cetera et cetera
there are completely different ways of
doing world history where you don't
actually intersect these topics very
much at all and they don't show up in
textbooks because they're not normally
adopted for teaching world history and
yet they are in their own sense world
histories there are numerous of them but
I'm particularly concerned with one
because I've thought about it in over
many years and written about it and I'm
going to give it talk about it today as
an example of an alternative way of
conceptualizing world history and this
is to conceptualize the issue the world
in terms of how humans live not with
each other but rather with animals to do
this you have to create stages and eras
and pick out developments single out
important individuals or important
places same sort of thing you would do
for a world history that focused on the
political realm or on the the nature of
property relations or something like
that it's just that there'll be
different ones because you're talking
about humans and animals
now what strikes me of the about this as
being in some ways a more satisfying way
to do world history is that you're not
starting at a with a single point and
saying let's zoom in on ancient Egypt or
let's zoom in on Mesopotamia with the
Indus Valley and talk about River Valley
civilizations in agriculture where
you're being selective from the very
outset
the way I look at the history of human
animal relations as I put it in my book
on hunter hunters herders and hamburgers
is that humans initially lived with
animals as animals there was some point
at which if we accept Darwinian theory
there's at some point at which our
ancestors had no more consciousness of
themselves as a as a distinctive species
than a chipmunk does they they were just
an animal
they had animals that they ran away from
and animals that they ate and animals
that they had sex with and animals that
they avoided because they were you know
would cause them to you know they had
stingers or cause them to itch or
something like that but by and large
they didn't even notice the other
animals and when you notice when you
look at animals in a in relationship to
one another one of the most interesting
things is how little interest they take
in one another unless they're of the
same species that's true there you can
see a nice video of a with chimpanzee
and going and pulling a dog's tail and
running away and that's kind of cute but
by-and-large not much interest in
animals and other animals unless they
have some sort of symbiotic relationship
or predator-prey relationship so the
first stage in the development of human
animal relations as opposed to simply
humans being animals is what I call
separation a process by which some
species in our line of of evolution came
to be aware that they were different or
that they were distinctive or that they
were conscious of themselves as a
species and other animals were different
in other word they were people and the
other animals were animals we don't know
when this was we don't know why it
happened we don't have any anything
other than conjecture to guess at what
may have caused early hominids also I
use hominid because we don't know
exactly when it occurred to see
themselves as being different from other
animals but we don't happened because we
don't we have a mentality very different
from chipmunks today when it comes to
looking up at the world and we see
ourselves as separate from animals that
had to start sometime now where it
started that's easier to say it almost
certainly started in East Africa because
there is it's very hard to imagine this
process not already being in train at
the time that modern Homo sapiens
sapiens left East Africa some fifty
thousand years ago and expanded around
the world so I think they took their
notion of of being a distinctive species
different from other animals with them
there's no particular indication that
they thought other animals were special
they were just different but over a long
period of time let us say a period of
something in the order of 30 or 40,000
years they gradually thought more and
more about about other animals
and the evidence for this shows up in
various ways but very strongly it shows
up in the pictures the visualizations
that humans created from the Paleolithic
era onward I'll say let's say from Oh
40,000 BC onward whether you are looking
at pictures in Australia or in Ice Age
caves in Spain or France or you know
early artistic remains from almost
anywhere in the world that go back let's
say over 20,000 years but even come up
much more recent be in some areas the
one thing that stands out is that the
most common category of image is as an
animal compared to which the lack of
images of plants is extraordinary
it's true you can find oh there's a corn
plant or there is a identifiable species
of tree so forth but for every
identifiable plant you have hundreds of
animal images and almost no human images
people wanted to make images of animals
but they weren't particularly drawn to
making images of themselves or or other
humans the
presence of animals accelerates as you
get closer and closer to the era of the
first domestic animals so you have a an
intensification of thinking about
animals or looking at animals
aesthetically normally when these images
are looked at anthropologists and
archeologists are inclined to think that
these animals that are shown up our food
animals there's very little evidence of
this case so to say images of an animal
being hunted or or being dead or being
carved into pieces those are extremely
rare images whereas you may have many
many many more images that show the
animal in motion and usually in a very
majestic fashion so we don't know
whether these were food images but by
the time you get to the first indication
of certain animals becoming domestic
it's fairly clear that there is an
identification of some animals with
supernatural beings so if you say at the
time of separation humans are saying you
know we're not animals we are humans and
animals are just animals and you go
along thirty thousand years later and
you have people saying we're not animals
we're humans but God is a giant bull or
our lineage descends from kangaroos or
something like that the the animals go
from being not us to being elevated
above us and we end up with this very
very strong
relationship of animals with with the
supernatural particularly with with
divinities we also have a plethora of
legends and beliefs that surely must go
back to a very early point that deal
with intersections between humans and
animals
I have to say that deal with beings that
are part human and part animal whether
it is a werewolf or a sent war or a
where Lama in Peru or whatever it is I
mean we people believe that there were
intersection scenes humans and animals
and they also very strongly believed
that there were situations in which
humans could actually either become
animals for the time being or kind of
channel animals and this is generally
falls into the category considered as
shamanism
that is to say religious beliefs that
question the boundary between humans and
animals so what you would you have with
this growing tendency is a boundary
issue where the humans stop and animals
begin initially imperii the separation
that is how do we rise above animals and
then increasingly it becomes what's the
boundary between us and animals that are
more powerful or faster or more
beautiful or more magnificent and more
indicative of a of some sort of
spiritual quality at this point
no I I call this this whole period the
period of pre domesticity but you're not
obvious that term matter of fact you're
not all we can remember anything at all
but but at the end of this pre domestic
pre domestic era these various human
societies have reached a very extensive
level of identification of animals and
it survives in various forms for
instance in costumes the use of feathers
the use of furs the use of animal masks
to have dances that will be imitated
imitative of animals ethnographers have
found thousands and thousands of of
instances of this sort of special status
of animals that survived down to modern
times and we don't know when they
originated but it seems likely that they
originated tens of thousands of years
ago in economic terms this period of pre
domestic human animal relations is often
referred to as a period of hunting and
gathering I do not fancy that term
because it tends to reduce human animal
relations to economic relationships to
say that hunting is what it's all about
and that the primary concern of the
people who painted pictures of bison and
horses and lions and so forth on the
walls of caves they know they were there
with their their brush or their stick
and a pot of paint and they are thinking
lunch lunch dinner dinner
good hunting lunch I
to eat this if you look at the species
distributions they don't particularly
match the species that were eaten
according to the bone census that you
could make of certain archaeological
sites they were the animals they wanted
to draw rather than ones that they were
compelled to draw because they were
hungry and I think that the reduction of
this to hunting really relates to the
strong materialist basis of the
anthropological discipline which I'm
actually quite attuned to in many cases
but not in this it seems to me that you
you have a let's say arise from the
spiritualization of animals so you have
to the point where we think we were
related to animals we can channel
animals we have gods are like animals so
with and so on and then we get the first
domestic animals that that thought that
the appearance of domestic animals is at
the end of a process that is very poorly
understood when you look at it purely
from the point of view of hunting when
you look at at this pre domestic
spiritualization or elevation of animals
you look at where it happened you find
it happens everywhere in the world
old world new world Australia the
importance of animals in the human
imagination and in human conceptions of
where humans stand in relation to the to
the animals that they live amongst that
increasing focus on animals occurs
everywhere then you get to this point
where you have the first domestic
species and what's what's so striking is
that this does not occur everywhere this
is very rare there are only a few places
where you
where you have the emergence of domestic
animal species people who talk about the
Neolithic Revolution as the beginning
point for a world historical narrative
say well this is when you have the
emergence of domestic plants and animals
which is not correct
because you have places that have
domestic plants that do not have
domestic animals this would be true say
of the precocious civilizations in the
New World and Peru in Mexico
other places where you have domestic
animals but but you don't have domestic
plants this would apply say to the early
cattle herding cultures of the Sahara
and the Sahel area south of the Sahara
there is really no relationship
intrinsic to the to the business of
domestic plants and animals it's rather
a carryover from the concept of hunting
and gathering that if you have a
foraging community which is the term I
would prefer foragers gather plant life
and hunt animal life therefore if you
move to a different stage in world
history where people are harvesting
deliberately planted plants then it
seems proper that they are that they now
move from hunting to harvesting animals
that are domestic animals so there's a
certain logic to it but it's the logic
that isn't born of a an examination of
the actual processes but rather is kind
of a continuation that you go from
hunting and gathering to domestic plants
and animals without asking whether that
makes any particular sense and I would
argue it doesn't make any particular
sense there is a large library of
literature dealing with the emergence of
domestic animals and it's it does not
converge onto a onto a very plausible
scenario we don't know how animals came
to be domestic my own feeling is that
each species became domestic in its own
way that you don't have a process that
was a replicatable
process that occurred with species a
species bees VCC and so forth this is
not the common view the common view is
that humans tried to domestic everything
to domesticate all animals and only
succeeded in a very small number of
cases of those cases being therefore
designated as the only animals that
could be domesticated and yet nobody
knows what the process was the the great
structuralist anthropologist Claude
ladies Straus poss you know observed
quite correctly that if you had some
animals or indeed if you had some plants
but let's stick with the animals if you
had some animals that were wild animals
and you wanted to domesticate them but
you would never seen a domestic animal
how could you want to domesticate it how
could you
visualize that this wild animal might
become a domestic animal when you didn't
know what an arrest kanima was no in the
first instances there can be no question
but what domestication was an
unanticipated an unanticipated outcome
of things that people had no grasp of
now lady Strauss says we must assume
that the people who lived at this
that this juncture had a scientific
spirit that led them to try
experimenting with different groups of
animals to see what would happen and
then lo and behold some of them became
domestic at which point the scientific
spirit disappeared not to reappear until
the 18th century in Western culture and
he's he talked about this as the savage
mind that there was a basic orientation
toward experiment toward trying things
to see what happened that must have
existed because there's otherwise how
could you account for certain groups of
animals becoming domestic at the other
end of the scale which is closer to
where I am in my thinking you have the
idea that animals became domestic by
themselves the animal that is
most frequently held up as an example of
self domestication is the cat
the earliest cats seem to come from
probably from Egypt the earliest cat
bones come from Cyprus but Cyprus has no
wild species from which the cat could
have derived therefore the domestic cat
had to already be there and be brought
to Cyprus by people in order to have
those bones appear so we don't have
bones going back to the earliest phases
of Egyptian society but there's a
stronger argument made that if more or
less coincides with the with the
beginnings of Agriculture in Egypt and
the notion of self domestication is that
when people started to grow grain and
plant rain it meant that every time they
harvested a crop they stored a very
substantial portion of the crop they
stored it so they would eat it during
the fallow year the path Paulo months of
the year and so they would have and so
that they would have seeds left to plant
at the beginning of the next plant
planting season the store grain
attracted rodents the rodents were the
favorite prey of small of small cats who
are native to to North Africa and indeed
there are cats that are really almost
indistinguishable in size and shape to
from from domestic cats that you can go
to zoos and see them so you had cats
that came into the community because
human communities were full of mice and
rats
and other grain eating vermin and the
humans were happy to have the cats eat
the vermin as long as they didn't eat
their babies as long as they didn't
think of the humans as being you know
objects that they should have hack so
the logic of it here is that when you
had cats that came into the human
community to eat the mice on their apps
any of those caps that was that appeared
to be ferocious was clubbed in the head
by the people and killed so the result
was the cats that were not that were not
killed were the most docile of the cats
and they're the ones that we produced
and afters a certain number of
generations they're the ones that become
the parent stock of domestic cats
because generation after generation only
the most docile of the cats in the
village will be allowed to live the
others will be killed or driven off then
once you have Buzzi cats that you can
trust to you know / and rub up against
you for food and so forth
then there's no need for the Wildcats
because you now have a domestic cat so
then you drive off all of the wild cats
and now you have domestic cats and you
breed them but you don't know how you
quite why you got them they just
suddenly appeared and it occurs over a
long enough period of time then nobody
would have had a memory of of the first
wild cats coming into the village
because we're talking about Oh
apparently something like thirty
generations before you get a completely
completely docile pussycat
once you have domestic cats then they
spread it isn't that you that people go
through this process everywhere because
once you have cats then you spread the
cats why because they eat the mice and
the rats so when you look at say the
history of China or Japan the evidence
would appear to indicate that cats
appeared in East Asia because they were
kept in Buddhist monasteries to kill the
mice and the rats but they were not
known in ordinary human settlements they
were brought in because the Buddhists
expanded eastward from from Afghanistan
and India and brought the Middle Eastern
cats with them so according to this
theory cats become domestic without
anyone knowing what's happening the same
argument is made in the case of pigs and
dogs
pigs and dogs are scavengers or they are
at least scavengers in part that means
they eat waste and garbage and so forth
and so on and there was nothing as full
of garbage as a human campsite so just
as the the grain growers had grain that
the mice and rats ate going back
apparently thousands of years earlier
human settlements had garbage in them
and the rats and the pigs or the dogs
and the pigs would come and eat the
garbage and if the dogs were ferocious
humans killed them if the pigs were
ferocious the humans killed them but
those that were sufficiently docile were
allowed to stay in the village because
it's always good to have some some way
to get rid of your garbage
this is very different from the idea
that humans domesticated dogs are
domesticated wolves I should say yeah
for hunting purposes it's very little
indication that dogs were used for
hunting in a you know in their earliest
in their earliest domestic incarnations
of course we don't know we we can say
that the humans hunted but we don't
really know whether they hunted using
the skills of the dog or whether the dog
went on the hunt to get the garbage the
only place where we have some reasonable
indication is in Australia where you had
Aboriginal peoples who arrived in
Australia 40,000 years ago dogs arrived
somewhere around 12,000 years ago we
don't know how and so you had dogs in
Australia that were the only species
that of mammals because the others were
were marsupials all the native fauna so
here you have one full mammalian species
and in the Australian language this
becomes the dingo which is a dog that
lives with humans but also is feral and
to say it it runs wild in many occasions
as opposed to being unchanged from the
wild so there have been people who have
looked at what is a relationship between
aboriginals Aboriginal people and
dingoes when the dogs came did the
Aborigines who were there before without
dogs did the Aborigines draw the dogs
into their hunting environment and the
answer appears to be no that the dogs
would go with the
original hunters so that if something
was killed the dogs would have something
to eat but they weren't used for
tracking they weren't used for attacking
they weren't used for protecting they
were there essentially to to scarf up
the garbage they were also used as pets
one specific that was rather surprising
was that you have aboriginal groups that
will break the legs of young dogs so
that they will be lame and unable to run
away so they'll have to stay in the
human community and eat the garbage but
they also are used you know if if it
gets cold and you have the campfire and
it's burned down but you'll come down to
coals on the night if you're lying there
on the ground the side of you that's
facing the fire is warm and your butt is
cold so it's been observed that a dingo
will be pulled up particularly the old
ladies you know come on you come up
behind me and keep my butt warm because
the vs. is what wives do with their
husbands as well but it's the the dog
appears to be a giver of comfort by
warmth and a satisfier of emotional
needs as a pet and this sort of we have
large areas of the world where feral
dogs are not used for anything at all in
Japan if you go back to the 18th century
there were lots of dogs and they were
often in a village but they weren't
owned by anybody but they were useful
because if somebody came to the village
the dogs would bark so they were not
watchdogs but they let you know what was
going on but nobody owned the dogs now
they weren't used for hunting they
weren't pets they were just there in
the so-called pariah dogs again they
were just there so it's true that
they're hunting peoples who use dogs for
hunting but dogs in general do not seem
to have a clear lineage of hunters I
think they do have a clear linear
lineage lineage as scavengers or garbage
pigs a little bit different because you
have two different patterns with pigs a
pattern that seems to emanate from
Southeast Asia where pigs primarily
lived in villages make garbage another
pattern that seems to be most common in
Southeast Europe which is where pigs
live in the forest and eat nuts and we
don't have a very clear notion of
domestic process with pigs except
probably they were domesticated in
numerous places and if the if the Native
Americans in the United States had been
inclined to have a domestic animal one
of the easiest animals they they would
have had available to domestic is the
javelina also known as the peccary which
is a wild animal in North America
particularly in the southwest is so of a
lot of javelinas around and it's a it's
not of the same genus as pigs but it
looks like a pig it acts like a pig if
it would serve the function and when the
Europeans came they said you know this
animal is easy to to domesticate if it's
tasty
it doesn't mind being around people but
we already have pigs so we don't need
another Pig
so the pecker he never gets domesticated
yeah you know species by species and
find patterns of domestication that do
not add up to a single process and I
don't think there ever was a process of
domestication
but the animals that we know most about
our cows sheep goats and around 8,000 BC
10,000 years ago and about five or six
thousand years ago horses and to a
lesser degree donkeys and camels these
species are better attested and it's
normally thought that you domesticated
these species so humans domesticated
species in order to get meat well
there's a problem with that because
supposing you go and you kill a wild a
wild cow and you bring home the baby
cows do you eat them or do you keep them
around until they have babies and then
do you eat those babies what when do you
eat them there's something very sort of
Calvinist about the whole thing you
bring in back to the camp
a lamb or a calf a docile infant and you
think I could have lamb chops or you
know veal parmesan tomorrow or I could
wait two years and then I could have it
but then you know if I want to keep me
out maybe I should wait four years maybe
we take 12 years I'll have a whole herd
then I can have a lot of lamb chops you
know this notion that you put off until
years in the future the pleasure of
meeting you might have now doesn't make
much sense unless of course you are
getting enough meat from hunting that
you have no need no need to eat the
little ones that you're keeping around
the camp then what do you keep them
around the camp for
what is striking about kind of the
earliest phase of an investigation of
cattle sheep and goats is the the
overlap between these domestic species
and em sacrifice by and large on a
worldwide basis human groups do not
sacrifice wild animals sacrifice here
meaning to deliberately kill the animal
in a ritual situation with some
conception that you are doing so in a
relationship to to supernatural beings
or some sort of supernatural situation
now you don't do it with wild animals
for a fairly obvious reason that if you
have chased an antelope down and you've
killed it then you can't sacrifice it
because you've already killed it the
alternative is to chase down the end of
the antelope kidnap it drag it home and
then sacrifice it when you get home
well the antelope may really disagree
with that you know bringing wild animals
into the camp for the purpose of
sacrificing them really makes almost no
sense unless of course they are young if
they're young then you can bring them in
if they're just kids or calves fawns but
they're grown animals you can't
sacrifice particularly cuz some of them
are very dangerous
the only wild animal they get sacrificed
with some repetition is the bear because
bears are pretty docile unless they of
course they get angry at you and you can
keep a bear for six months or a year and
then sacrifice it when it's bear killing
time
but by and large the only animals that
you can that you can sacrifice on a
reliable basis are the ones you already
have
so maybe they brought in the young cows
or sheep or goats and didn't avail
themselves of the lamb chops or the veal
chops right away because I thought we'll
save these for a special occasion you
know where there's a drought and we need
rain will sacrifice one of these animals
and God will bring rain or something
like that there's a high correlation
between sacrifice and domestic animals
in the process of a sacrifice but
normally happened was that under ritual
conditions often with chanting and so
forth an animal would be killed and then
the animal would be cooked and select
portions would be cooked under
circumstances where the aroma or the
smoke or the flesh were supposed to
please the God and the rest would be a
barbeque so one sacrifice begins it's
it's really basically a barbecue
situation we'll kill an animal and you
socialize the meat so the person who has
the animals is the one who is the great
man of the village because he's the one
who could give meat to the whole village
in Indian culture he was called the
Yamata the the person who provides the
animals for the sacrifice you have
another group of ritual specialists who
chant the hymns jimana that's about it
doesn't do anything he just sits there
while the animal is being sacrificed and
then presides over the meat being given
away so the the owners of animals become
identified as the the meat givers for
the community
if you give a lot of meat and you say
you know you've all come here and you've
all eaten all my meat and I'm happy to
have you here happy to entertain you and
I'd like you to call me King from now on
now you have the origin of kingship it's
may have a little more complicated map
but not a whole lot because the
provision of meat is very different from
the provision of a vegetable stuff you
know you did not have people who who
grew wheat and know let's say made
unleavened bread said all right bread
for everybody no because everybody was
growing wheat may have made their own
brand it wasn't a big deal but
throughout history hunting and royalty
have been very very closely conjoined
and hunting comes to be seen as an
analogue for war but also a ruler is
seen as a great ruler partly in
relationship to his prowess in hunting
as shows up in images going back to 3000
BC the image of the King killing animals
you don't have parallel images of the
king planting crops no here's a sir
Nasser Powell ploughing you don't see
that now there are some famous legendary
rulers who are who were associated with
the bringing of agriculture the Yellow
Emperor in China or Jamshid and the
Persian tradition but by and large it's
the it's the animal keepers who become
the prototype of the of the monarchy
why did they sacrifice one of the most
common ethnographic findings of modern
foraging communities is that killing
animals brings into brings the killer
into a state of guilt that the animals
spirit is offended by being killed
either individually or as a species so
you have time and time again
examples of rituals prayers or sayings
in which Hunter's apologize to their
prey for killing them apologize to their
prey and say we're only killing you
because we need we need the food and
this is part of this growing tendency to
aestheticized and sacrifice animals that
you have in the late point before you
start getting domestic animals so
sacrifice is a continuation of that it
is not that you sacrifice the animals as
an apology to the animals when you
sacrifice the animals as a you
ritualized the sacrifice in order to
gain the forgiveness of some higher
spirit for it for killing the animals
and you don't limit it to what you want
to eat instead the sacrifice unlike
hunting is unlimited the more animals
you can provide the greater the
sacrifice so you know in the Iliad where
you have Hecate ohms meaning a hundred
cattle sacrificed we think literally
that you had hundreds and hundreds of
animals that were sacrificed and that by
the time of the let's say by the time of
Jesus
virtually all meat that was available in
the cities of the Roman Empire
came from the temples it was all
sacrificed meat because producing meat
without a ritual situation was
considered wrong it instantly you think
of this and then you think of how when
Cain and Abel present the first fruits
of their endeavors God prefers the first
fruits of Abel who is the animal herder
to the first fruits of Cain who's the
grower of grain and so Cain kills Abel
out of jealousy the animal keeper in
this social situation is supreme but it
means that this pattern of hunting
animals in in sacred situations isn't
necessarily a universal feeling what
seems to be universal is the idea that
you apologize to the animals the idea
that you that it becomes divinized at a
higher level seems to be geographically
narrower so in areas where you have
animals that could be could become
domestic say north america where you
could domesticate bison or or caribou it
never happens because domestication is
not a practical thing it's not an
economic thing it is initially a
something that is part of the social
functioning of the group with respect to
the acquisition of meat most people in
the world over most early periods were
perfectly happy just to eat meat that
was gained by hunting or fishing the
idea that you should grow your own meat
which we take is almost a defining
factor of civilization there's a very
uncommon idea and you have even modern
societies that really have never taken
to the idea of growing animals for food
Japanese society down to World War two
a primarily the produce of the sea and
not and not whales but whales never been
that popular in Japan so so you have
this this domestication that in my mind
is pretty much a continuum along here
that is to say as you get more myths
more legends of human animal relations
more questioning of the spiritual
boundary between humans and animals more
sac realization and so forth the
domestication comes in at this juncture
in certain areas that happen to have
certain religious or ritual practices
the animals were only used for that
there is you know sheep if you go back
to ten thousand years ago people had
domestic sheep but there was no wool
wild sheep don't have wool so wool comes
along later as what one major scholar
Andrew Shara calls a secondary utility
there apparently is a lapse of time of
several thousand years before there are
types of sheep that have wool there's a
lapse of time of several thousand years
before people start to drink milk the
before people start to use animals to
plow now all these things are now
classified as secondary utilities
because we have fairly concrete evidence
of when wool and plowing and milking
come in and it's not until well after
the first archaeological evidence of
domestication so what what we end up
with is that when you have domestic
species of these major quadrupeds
initially say if you have an axis here
of
Oh graphing spiritual importance or uses
against economic utility initially you'd
have a pretty high level for ritual or
sacredness of animals and a fairly low
level of utility because you're still
getting much or most of your animal
protein from animals that you're hunting
over time particularly as secondary
utilities are discovered the the
economic utility goes up and the
spiritual utility goes down the study of
of human animal relations pretty much
comes in at this point at a point where
it's assumed that domestic animals are
primarily useful and indeed they're made
people who would sort of say domestic
animals are useful animals certain
animals that are born wild like
elephants become useful and therefore
talk about domestic elephants even
though they're not born in captivity
whereas the spiritual side of animals
gets to be relegated to insignificance
because that is seen to be primitive and
savage and unacceptable so that
sacrifice blood sacrifice tends to
disappear or to become metaphorical gods
that have human characteristics blended
with animal characteristics are
supplanted by gods that are entirely
human notions like werewolves and
centaurs are written off as myths and
shamanism where you have a priest who
tries to channel an animal spirit is
considered to be a sign of savagery
said you have economic utility as being
the overwhelming property of animals the
the what this means is that the division
between domestic animals and wild
animals which is rather slight at this
beginning point because you've
spiritualize your wild animals and
you're coming off of that period that
becomes greater and greater so by the
17th century the smartest people in
Europe according to the to the modern
index of smart people in Europe doesn't
say the first enlightenment geniuses
began to think that animals are simply
machines that they are 100 percent
economically useful entities and they
have no spiritual or affective
characteristics at all
this is particularly associated with the
thinking of of Descartes who wrote in
numerous of his writings about how
animals are simply God's cuckoo clocks
humans can make a mechanized device and
God makes mechanized devices that are
simply cleverer than the human ones
but like the human ones they have no
feelings they have no memory
they have no anticipation they have no
they have no spirit and therefore if you
want to find out how medicine operates
or surgery you simply cut open an animal
and you certainly don't work here care
if the animal screams or cries because
God designed it that way it's like
having a cuckoo clock that when you if
you open the front door it goes don't
don't take me apart you know if it's
just it's just a delusion there's no
pain because you have to you know one of
the things that happens in here is that
in this span of time
the notion that humans are totally
different from animals comes to be the
doctrine in societies where you have
domestic animals you know initially you
had human separating cells from animals
then they begin in the late pre domestic
period to to develop rather elevated
feelings about animals and now they've
made the difference between animals and
humans has become absolute sanction of
course by the Bible by the Quran as the
two major books of the most of these
societies the most heavily used to
message animals and wild animals retain
a certain amount of nobility so the
notion of hunting a hunting big game
still has a certain cachet because only
a mighty hunter can hunt big game but to
slaughter a sheep well that's kind of
like you know opening a hungry man
dinner
it's how sheep has no more feeling than
that then that microwavable plate of
food does in other parts of the world
this did not occur and there are other
things that do occur and the most the
most common one of course is that people
do not consume much in the way of meat
from domestic animals but rather they
continue to hunt and fish and they may
have a few domestic animals like the
like the dwarf goats of sub-saharan
Africa but but by and large they don't
eat very much meat and what they get
from hunting and fishing is its
sufficient but then you have another
important subculture that occurs within
the domestic arena and that consists of
pastoral nomads who keep tens and
thousands of animals of the same species
normally
and they they heard them and they see to
their to their survival lead them to
food and water and so forth and so on
and these domestic herds do not really
yield a whole lot of meat because they
are valuable in and of themselves they
exist as property like gold coins or
jewels or you know euros they exist as
property and if you spend it you don't
have it well spending it with an animal
means that it's dead now you're eating
it
you're eating it but but now you your
property has been diminished so they
tend to hold animals often way in excess
of those that are easily sustained by
the ecosystem they're in are they hold
those animals because they are
indicators of wealth they consume
secondary products like you know wool or
pear or milk but they don't eat a lot of
the animals obviously you only have
pastoral nomads in areas that have
domestic animals but also have enough
space that is not readily usable for
agriculture to have free ranging space
for these animals so let's say then that
you have by the time you get to Oh 1800
or so you have animals are in certain
categories one category is entirely
utilitarian you grow animals you cut
them up you fry them you eat them
another one is that you grow them as a
pastoral nomads they are wealth you
sustain them but you don't kill them a
lot another one is that you really don't
have much in the way of domestic animals
that you use the animals and the fish
that you have have in your environment
there's a turning point that sets iam
seemingly in the eighteenth century that
has two aspects of it and the
relationship between those two aspects
has been debated is being debated one of
those aspects is the growth of humane
feelings this is particularly in Britain
although not exclusively in Britain but
pretty close to exclusively in Britain
it has to do with feelings that grow
among the most the most enlightened
segments of society that it's wrong to
simply kill animals wanton ly Britain
probably had more want and killing of
animals than though they are any other
country in Europe from what we we know
of that period the idea of simply
enjoying watching animals kill each
other or enjoying killing the animals
ourselves was was intense in Britain and
it had lost the quasi-military
rationale that it had in earlier
centuries where you would have a hunt
that was supposed to keep your army on
its toes and also the great hunts of
earlier times since you know
desensitized people to to killing
another animal up close and personal
that if you you know bash a deer on the
head and you made just as easily bash a
human on the head but in Britain in the
night of the 18th century say tying up a
bull and setting dogs on it or a bare
bull baiting and bear baiting things
like that
gradually are seen to be pretty hideous
practices and there's a great deal
written on the growth of humane feeling
in Britain but there's a simultaneous
thing that is growing in other parts of
the world but primarily in parts of the
world inhabited by people who speak
English that is to say the United States
Canada Australia and New Zealand and
this is the growth of the ranching
industry ranching and pastoral nomadism
have similarities in that you have huge
quantities of animals taken care of by a
very small number of people on Range
land that is not suitable for
agriculture the difference is that with
a pastoral nomadic society every animal
is valuable in its lifetime because the
quantity of your wealth like the
quantity of your of your gold coins is
defined by how many animals you have in
the new world which had no domestic
animals that had huge amounts of space
that animals could live in and the and
the animals of the Europeans brought
reproduced with incredible abundance in
Canada United States Mexico and
Argentina in particular
most of the animals couldn't possibly be
used and it was a very unusual situation
you had let's say probably millions of
animals that the majority of which were
not owned by anybody every animal in the
old in the old world was owned very
domestic animal and the new world most
of them were not owned and there was no
way to the people did not see them as
sources of wealth on the hoof they only
became sources of wealth when you sold
their parts so the ranching industry
grows up making its money a quiet you
know realizing its wealth through the
killing and dismemberment of animals
rather than through maintaining them as
wild wild livestock no society that has
had no country that's had a large and
active passional nomadic society has yet
succeeded in converting their animal
husbandry to a ranching society because
if they're just contradictory ranching
says kill animals sell the pieces and
have pasture no madam Rossum says it'll
hold the animals have helped them
reproduce and you increase your wealth
to different totally different concepts
of wealth but the ranching fed into the
growing humane feelings the idea that it
is that just killing animals because
they're sort of machines or they're just
products is bad because it's inhumane
and yet on the other hand world history
is shown in modern times that every time
you have a significant increase in per
capita income meat-eating increases so
granting gets bigger and bigger and
bigger particularly once you get
refrigeration and salting and other ways
of preserving meat and
and distributing it the the overlapping
particularly in the english-speaking
world of ranching that is to say the
production of a maximum amount of meat
and the realization of wealth by killing
animals comes into contradiction with
the idea of humane treatment of animals
and this grows in the 19th century
particularly in the 20th century and
this to my mind is where we come to the
end of the road for the whole concept of
domestic animals because domesticity has
created irresolvable conflicts that are
moral that are intellectual in which you
have people who profoundly believe that
it was wrong to kill animals and eat
them particularly domestic animals and
yet at the same time the society is
producing more and more on beat in the
post-world War two ERA in in the United
States and in particular you have a
profound separation between humans and
animals so that means is no longer you
know cut from a you know from a a
hanging piece of a carcass but is rather
packaged on a plastic tray and covered
with with transparent film you no longer
have people living on farms you no
longer have horses pulling vehicles in
cities you've gotten to a point where
there is virtually no contact between
humans and animals except for pets
particularly dogs horses and cats
and in fiction movies television
cartoons so forth that becomes the new
locus of human-animal relations it is in
this context that you start to get the
development of what I call sort of post
domestic anxieties people who feel that
the issue of
animal rights or animal pain or animal
exploitation is as important in their
view of the world as as human rights or
human pain or human exploitation so the
animal rights movement becomes the
political spearhead of the post domestic
era
I apologize for you introducing another
post word we have a lot of post words
but this one is rather interesting
because it isn't simply a matter of
humane 'no sand and industrial
exploitation of animals coming together
to produce a revulsion and feelings of
guilt but it's also opens a new chapter
in people's effort to understand the
relationship between humans and animals
so you actually have if you come up to
the post domestic era you have a
reversion to an earlier time as people
begin to say how are we different from
animals and people become fascinated by
things like how do animals communicate
how does human speech relate to to
animal vocalization does the
organisation of human society in some
ways mirror the organization of termite
or ant society or the organization of
chimpanzee society maybe we need to
study chimpanzees and orangutangs and so
forth with intense
interest because their their who we used
to be and some people will will go to do
two extremes I would say in trying to
reconnect the severance between humans
and animals that comes in in this late
period of domestic existence this has a
carryover into the area of religion in
which people try to reinterpret their
religious traditions in ways that will
be Pro vegetarian and humane to animals
so that if the Torah says that you shall
not work on the seventh day on the
Sabbath it also says neither should your
animal work on the Sabbath as if your
animal is going to go to work without
you
know you were I'll take the Sabbath off
but you know basta you go out there and
plow all by yourself here but hey it's
not quite clear what was all meant by
that but it's very hard to to get away
from the fact that ancient Judaism had
blood sacrifice and that if the temple
was ever rebuilt on Temple Mount in
Jerusalem there will be blood sacrifice
again and then you know huge numbers of
Americans they eel they're you know
they're slaughtering animals in
Jerusalem why did we work so hard to get
that temple rebuilt I got an email once
from a person who read my book on
animals and he you know actually it was
an email was a review and he said the
really interesting book learned all
sorts of important things I wish I
remember a long time ago but then I've
discovered that the author is profoundly
wrong on certain things for example he
denies that Jesus and the disciples are
vegetarians
and I thought gee the loaves and the
fishes that's not the loaves and the doe
foo meat substitute those are loaves and
fishes and what is Jesus Jesus is the
Lamb of God who sacrificed for you and
for many and when you take the cup you
know this is my blood you take the bread
this is my body and yep this is now
being recast as a vegetarian
tradition and then at the same time you
have the idea that pets are really
pretty much human they're you know you
relate to your pet in the 21st century
as closely as you relate to that sister
you've never liked very much matter of
fact you're much closer to your pet your
pet always understands you you
understand the pet so in America a
legend was started about 50 years ago
that when your pet dies and you'll find
this in any handout from a pet cemetery
or a pet grief counseling officer or
anything like that
when your pet dies it goes to the
Rainbow Bridge and the Rainbow Bridge is
a sunny meadow where your pet will play
and gamble in the sunshine all day long
every day until one day it sees you
coming over the horizon and it runs it
leaps into your arms and you cross the
Rainbow Bridge together into paradise
you know check it out in Google look how
many hits you get for Rainbow Bridge and
they're all American this was a
anonymous essay written by a pet lover
about 50 years ago published in a pet
magazine and it sort of went viral in
the pre in the pre YouTube era and so
now it's used all over the place because
the idea that you would
ah then you would not be with your pet
is you know you that's that's not what
the hereafter is for and so you can read
books like boy Jesus and his dog you can
also buy the sweatshirt on the internet
boy Jesus there's a dog whom he converts
to to be his friend then the dog goes
back to its original owner and who is
someone who was imprisoned and tortured
by the Romans for his belief in the
Messiah and then finally the owner is
dying and and Jesus now comes and
reconnects with the dog and the owner
says I just hoped I'd live long enough
to see the Messiah and Jesus says you
have and so Mary and just like what what
you're have been fine I never knew but
the dog do and then Jesus and the dog
are going to it says Jesus and the dog
will be in heaven together now these are
things that would have been utterly
inconceivable two hundred years ago and
while most societies in the world are
not engaged in this sort of post
domestic set of strange attitudes it's
growing in America and growing you and
pastor in Britain and is likely I think
in the over the next couple of decades
to become the successor to you know
freeing the slaves getting women the
vote civil rights movement you know gay
and lesbian equality and animal rights
and my guess is that animal rights is
going to emerge at the next stage in
world history as an international issue
it's like right now where you have
someone saying well we wouldn't want to
have Muslims win a vote in Egypt because
they would
abolish drinking and oppress women okay
that could be debated but we may go to
the point in 20 years ago I'd say well
we wouldn't want the exes to come to
power in country why because they'll
kill animals and we need to protect the
animals so as a theme in world history
this is one that is global it has stages
it has dramatic events it has crucial
text has important individuals and it's
undergone a profound change literally
during during our lifetimes as post
domestic anxieties have emerged as being
so important to a major segment of the
American community but you can't do this
kind of world history in something
that's called world history because
world history is supposed to be a lot of
people and this is about people and
animals together but it's only one of a
score of different world histories that
might be imagined that would not be
modeled implicitly although not
explicitly on the evolution of politics
and the evolution of of the economy
which is what we have in the world
history narratives that are before us
not only in my textbook but in other
textbooks and in most of the trade books
related to world history that are
available so that's the capsule history
of human animal relations if you want
details I have a book called hunters
herders and hamburgers that gives us all
at exhaustive detail not exhaustive
delightful detail and on Thursday I will
give a final lecture about world history
to finish the course and I woke up 3:18
morning this morning with the idea for
the lecture so I'll see you all that